um
okay so today uh we're finishing up the
cons this is our last
content day of the semester and so it's
fitting that we end with this guy
who kind of puts everything into a
perspective not necessarily
perspective per se maybe aristotle would
have been better for that
but kant certainly puts things in a very
clear
maybe rigid perspective that we talked
about this last class i think some of
you can identify
with this if for you duty is what is
primary
duty is more important than happiness or
virtue
or pleasure or anything like that then
you are
most likely either a conscient or
somebody in great sympathy with
conscience or deontology
we talked about the goodwill last time
now we're going to look at
sort of the nuts and bolts of kant's
ethical system
and he's interested in this idea of
imperatives
in order to get to that we've got to
think a little bit about laws
so and about human beings and about
other
other kinds of beings so the universe
is governed by loss that's what they
teach you in in some classes
right in your natural science classes
perhaps even in your what we call human
sciences or social sciences classes they
told you
things along those lines or economics
and if you are studying business you
know
law of supply and demand so what are
laws laws are
generalizations are supposed to cover
everything let's think about a law that
governs all physical objects
what's something that you can say about
all physical objects
gravity gravity okay yeah i figured that
one will come up
so gravity is going to affect this it's
going to affect this
it's going to affect this all equally
right
same effects um if if i
fall out of a window i'm like a set of
keys in that respect if you fall out of
a window
we're all going to fall we're all going
to be attracted to the greater mass of
the
center of the earth
no exceptions for human beings because
we are physical objects in the world
among other things if i drop my iphone
which i'm not going to do because you
know i'm not going to attempt faith
even though i have you know the one of
the strongest
cases available for it because i'm
clumsy
clumsy
if i drop that it should fall as well
laws allow us to predict what's going to
happen they allow us to get our head
around what's going to happen
there's other laws governing say
behavior
and what are some generalizations you
can make about
animals before we go to human beings
what are some generalizations you can
make about animals
maybe they don't have to be completely
true in every case but
most often true yeah
yeah okay they all hunt let's say they
all
get food in some way and that's
true of all animals except for dead
animals right they're no longer
looking for food but while they were
living yeah every every single thing
that's living
has to have a source of food that's part
of what it means to be
living now let's step it up a little bit
more are there any generalizations you
can make about human beings
that maybe aren't true in every single
case but are generally true
think about your majors what have you
been studying
what does it taught you about human
beings
those of you who are in say business or
social sciences or education or
things like that what have you learned
about human beings again
there's just
like uh i don't know we need to have
other people
in our life okay so we we have
what we're going to desire to be
accepted socially so okay so
ability and a desire for acceptance
is general to human beings does that
mean every single one has that
um no there are some people who
just don't care one bit about other
people
some of them because they're sociopathic
we've talked about sociopathy a little
bit before
you want to stay away from those people
especially if you recognize them
yeah now does it cover every single
human being no because we're
a different kind of creature than say
iphones or books or dogs
or things like that what what changes
things for us
what if somebody makes a rule
and you're aware
you have a choice then right whether to
go along with the rule
or sometimes just to break it or
sometimes to
actually subvert the rule you're
different
than other things in the universe
because you're rational we've talked
about this before right that capacity
for reason
means that you can do something
that the iphone can't the iphone is a
tool
it's like a servant or a slave it does
what i tell it to do sometimes it
frustrates me because it takes too long
to do things
where it wants to update its software
and inconvenient times but ultimately
it's doing what i make it do right that
camera
it goes on it goes off uh last class it
went off too early but that's because i
didn't charge it enough
provided i do the things that i i'm
supposed to do it will do
its job these lights if the light goes
out
we don't we don't try to reason with it
and i'll say
you understand that being a good light
means you have to go on
when we turn you on don't you
let's try it again you know we flip the
switch and now the light goes on
that's not what we do with with physical
objects right
some people try to reason with their
pets
now now you know little doggie i told
you not to
to attack the the cat that's not very
nice
does the dog actually hear any of that
or think about it does a dog you know i
would like to be a good dog
and being a good dog requires that i do
xyz
therefore i'll do xyz i mean the dog
might actually modify its behavior but
it's responding basically to
food affection lack of affection getting
smacked
you know things like that right you're
different
since you've been a kid people have been
reasoning with you
you probably think back to the first
thing you ever did wrong
and maybe you were punished and they
just said don't ever do that again
right and you started thinking about it
what happened i didn't like that
better not do that again or maybe they
tried to reason with you and say you
know
you shouldn't do this because that hurts
people
and you don't want to hurt people do you
no no
and then what's going on there is you're
actually a reasoning being
you're a rational being you can change
your own
will and a dog can't
a dog can't step back and say i want to
be a different kind of dog
we you know it could be that maybe
chimps can do that
we don't know because the culture that
chimps have for the most part is what
we've given them
the chips that can do sign language
that's because we taught them to do sign
language
human beings you know even even a
you know fairly unintelligent human baby
is smarter than a chimp baby that's
going to develop
way beyond what a chimp is going to do
because it's going to think about its
own life and it's going to think about
what it ought to do because that's part
of what it is to be human that's going
to discuss this with other people
and it's going to change its will over
time
how do you then decide what you're going
to do
well one way to think about this is in
terms of giving yourself
commands or rules
you don't often i i suppose think of it
this way
you don't think to yourself hey the
action that i'm doing right here
is a kind of action that fits a kind of
class of action
you often just engage i need to do this
now now i need to do this think about
how you got here
right how many of you drove
so about 60 of the class
think about all the different actions
that were required to get you here
you had to go out start the car
maybe you let it run for a while maybe
you didn't i don't know it depends on
how rushed you were
you had to do all those complex
movements that that you know get your
car
here you steer at the right time
all of those were sort of rule-governed
movements choices that you made if
anybody else wanted to do the same
thing they would have to do the same
movements right
or can they just do anything they like
when you're driving a car can you do
anything you like
what happens then you
there's a lot of ways to go along with
the car um
now think about the rest of the actions
you can think of each one of those
actions that you do is not just what you
yourself do but what somebody else in
that situation
if they want to accomplish the things
that you do
want to do
and other people can share your motives
and you can talk about those
you can recognize yourself in these
philosophies that we've been studying
you can recognize other people in them
too
because we're not totally unique
and we can share these things and
compare with each other
that's also part of what it is to be
human
to be able to do that you know that
expression no man is an island
it's actually more like you know every
single person is kind of like a
big interconnected set of roads
leading to everybody else because we're
so comparable
um now one way like i said we can
understand this is in terms of what we
call imperatives or comp calls
imperatives and an imperative think of
it as a command or a rule
so if i say okay everybody stand up and
spin around and then sit back down
that's telling you what to do right
that's an imperative if i say
on thursday you will
take the
student evaluations so bring a number
two pencil
if you can um that's giving you a rule
right you should by even if i say
something like
in every case where you have to take a
student evaluation
you should have a number two pencil i'm
not expressing it in the imperative mood
but i'm expressing it as a sort of
command or rule for you right
if i say don't kill anybody that's also
a command isn't it
that's a rule if i say if somebody
messes with you
hurt them so badly that they will never
mess with you again
that's also a command isn't it um
if i give you a long you know connected
thing if you're in the condition
a and b happens and c happens but d
doesn't happen then you should do e
that's also a command
that's also a rule isn't it it's a
complicated rule but it's a rule
so you can think of your reactions
in terms of the rules that they are are
following or not following
think about the ten commandments again
the ten commandments are
commands right the rules that the
natural law told you to do
do good and avoid evil that's a command
you should pursue happiness that's a
command
try to maximize the general
happiness the utilitarianism that's a
command
as well so all these types of moral
theory
can all be brought in terms of commands
how you ought to behave
now khan talks about three different
kinds of commands
or imperatives and one of these is what
he calls rules of skill
so you know for instance if you're going
to take the
the student evaluation clear thing
and you wanted to count what do you have
to do
you set it a minute ago bring your
number two pencil great not only bring a
number two pencil but
use a number use the number two pencil
right because you could bring in number
two pencil
and then fill it in with with the ink
and then they won't count your response
which i guess you know do you do you
care
how many of you care about student
evaluations raise your hands
none of you actually care because you've
done a lot of them right
you know what they're for right why do
we have this
yeah so it's evaluating the teacher um
their performance in their job it's also
evaluating like the class how you feel
about the class
i haven't actually looked these over you
guys have something like 30 questions to
answer
which by the way doesn't make a good
evaluation because one of the things we
do know about evaluations
after about question number 10 people
put care
in general and and some some people are
conscientious and a lot of people start
filling this stuff
in so if you want your evaluation to be
a good evaluation
then you should make it very short and
sweet
notice what i did there if you want this
then you should do this if you want your
evaluation to be a good evaluation
that's a if that statement it's a
hypothetical
then you should make it in this way
maybe you don't care
maybe you maybe the reason for giving
evaluations is to make these students
jump through hoops
or to you know check off some stuff on
boxes so it looks like we're doing a
really thorough evaluations if that's
the case then maybe you should make it
you know like 100 questions
different rules of skill for different
if-then
it all depends on the if part do you
really want this
if you want your evaluation account then
you have to fill it out in number two
pencil
do you want your evaluation account does
it does it really matter to you
i mean i think it should but i'm not you
i haven't had to fill out student
evaluations for
what like
15 years so
i'm not in the case that you are you
know whether
you care about it maybe some of you care
and some of you don't
so maybe some of you will bring the
number two pencils maybe some of you
won't
but if you wanted to to take place then
if you want to produce that effect
of the the evaluation counting you have
to do this
medical knowledge is like this too
if you want somebody to be healthy
what are the sort of things you need to
do
what's you guys don't remember health
problems or let me put it through this
one what are some things you shouldn't
do if you want to be healthy
yeah i think that's eliminated yeah
don't don't eat junk food
every single day you've all have you all
seen super sized meat you saw that guy's
progression
that kind of shows you you know don't
don't eat uh mcdonald's every day
but i suspect if you live just out of
doritos it probably wouldn't be any
better
with it doritos and mountain dew you
know
with the the occasional taco bell
if you want to be healthy then don't do
that
well maybe some people don't care if
they're healthy or not
maybe that's not a value for them if it
is a value then that rule would apply
but if it isn't then
no big deal if you're a diabetic what do
you have to take
insulin if you want to
live right but a diabetic who who
doesn't want to live anymore
maybe they don't just take insulin
anymore
right
a rule of skill depends completely on
whether
you do in fact have that motivation
now think back to what concept about our
our motivations for things
each one of you has your own set of
motivations
your inclinations and desires do you all
have exactly
the same ones
well think about what you're majoring in
right that ties in with your
inclinations and desires
do you all have the same majors
no no no so you know right off the bat
that let's just take classes for example
let's say
you're a business major right business
finance was it
yeah business finance okay so um
what's what's the upper-level class that
you had to take uh financial marriage
financial management how many how many
of the rest of you took financial
management
for your business major too right okay
so
you two share the same motivation for
that
if you want to not only you know get
your major
graduate but understand how to do
business well
how to finance things you need to take
financial management
the rest of you didn't take it because
that that doesn't fit into your
pattern of desires and inclinations
doesn't
you took other classes that maybe mr
wilby
and mr george didn't take right
rules of skill they can provide us
guidelines
but it's always dependent on whether you
actually want this or that
let's move on to councils on prudence
kant does say there's something that all
of you do want
there is a common motivation that you
have
it's the same one that arizona thought
you have
what is it
happiness as the satisfaction
of all your desires and inclinations um
do any of you know offhand
what all of your desires and
inclinations are
right now you know what some of them are
right
but have you ever had the experience of
doing something that you haven't done
before and suddenly you realize oh wow i
really like this
or the opposite experience this is awful
i'm never doing this again
either case has to do with desires and
inclinations if you want to avoid that
thing that's an inclination to avoid it
if you want to repeat that great
experience
that's that's a desire inclination as
well
and you so you don't know right now what
all your desires and inclinations are do
you
do you have any idea what they're going
to be five ten years from now
some general idea right you don't want
anyone to go out and you know poke you
walk around just poking you all day
right
is that gonna change i hope not
this shouldn't provided you're saying
are you going to still like to eat a lot
of the same stuff you like to eat
probably are you going to still want to
do the same things that you're
doing now it's harder to say isn't it
what do you think you guys are
between like 20 for the most part 20 to
22.
is that about right you guys have
experienced a lot
you've gone through k through 12 and you
went to college college is a very
different
experience for you you guys are
not like freshmen freshmen are just sort
of figuring out
what's going on you guys have gathered
some experience some of you have done
some traveling
um how many times have your your desires
and inclinations changed over the course
of your life
from your experience now at this point
just a few times
quite a quite a few what do you think
i'm willing to bet they've changed quite
a bit there may be some things that will
stick with you forever
but you don't actually know which ones
are which i mean i at your age
i thought that i would still enjoy
um i used to work out three hours a day
a lot of it doing endurance lifting and
martial arts and stuff like that
do i look like somebody who works out
three hours a day
what do you think well
maybe i just quit last week
yes no no um my desire
my desires and inclinations change i
actually started getting bored
with exercise that's part of why i don't
do as much as i should
um it just got really dull for me my
desires and inclinations changed to
sitting around doing doing philosophy
reading books
writing talking with people that sort of
thing
so you do have this common motivation
of happiness but you don't know exactly
what's going to make you happy
the best thing that you can have then is
still hypothetical stuff
if this is what makes you happy and in
general these sort of things make people
happy
like say how many of you want to not
necessarily be stinking rich you know
like totally wealthy
but independent financially independent
not all of you i mean it's a good thing
there's no shame in saying that you want
to be financially independent as a
matter of fact
it's a good thing because then you're
not a burden on anybody else right
um providing you didn't make your money
by killing people or
you know stealing or anything like that
um
that is something you can count on but
kant says that's merely empirical that's
merely something that we learn from
experience
um so we could say well if you want to
be happy then you should
use your council of prudence it would be
prudent for you
to find ways of becoming financially
independent
is that going to look the same way for
each one of you
no probably not um
as a matter of fact some of some of you
are probably going to be at an advantage
in that i can say just right now knowing
your your majors not not actually
knowing your character so that's going
to
be an advantage but mr wilby is going to
have a considerable advantage over many
of you because
business finance that's a pretty good
way to go to generate wealth
pre-med that's a pretty good way to go
as well you know
if you want to be financially
independent philosophy professor
not such a great way for for financial
independence
and i'm not trying to dissuade anybody
from philosophy
but i just want to you know again we can
give councils of prudence if you want to
be
wealthy there are certain things that
you want to shoot for
do you want to be healthy is health an
important part of your happiness
yeah if you want to be healthy you
probably need to
do a few things like some exercise like
you know paying attention to diet
not engaging in certain risky behaviors
those are just councils of prudence
though
those are still hypothetical they're not
categorical
and nobody's saying those are bad things
they're just not yet
good things they're not yet what we want
to
focus on in ethics classes
commands of morality for kant they have
to be absolute
they have to apply to everybody there
can't be any
well if you want this then you ought to
do this
if you want to be happy then you ought
to do this
they have to be you should do this and
that's it
no ifs ands or buts
so let's let's how do we figure out
those sorts of things
kant talks about
what he calls a categorical comparative
and
there are three formulations
we're only going to look at two of them
in any sort of detail
but we'll put them all up
so here's formulation one act
as if i'm going to abbreviate a little
bit
the maximum of your action
we're to
become
a universal law
second one act
so as to treat humanity
this is an important part in yourself
and others
always as
an end
not just a means
as a matter of fact since we're getting
short on space i'm just going to read
you the third one
every reactional being must so act as as
if
he were through his maxim always a
legislating member in the universal
kingdom of ends
that one there's there's you know a
little bit of debate about what does
that mean
in khan scholarship so i'm going to
avoid that one and that one is not very
easy to use
these two are pretty easy to use this is
sort of the procedures
by which you can figure out whether
something
according to kant is right or wrong
good or bad this one has a couple
different parts to it
first thing is this word maxim right
there's a magazine called maxim
this has nothing to do with that you
know it's not about drinks or women
or cars or well i mean it could be but
it has no necessary connection with that
a maxim
is a rule a
guideline so
i decide that i'm going to call off
class
thursday even though you're supposed to
have a review session
because i'm just tired of the semester
and i don't feel like going to class
that's that's a description of my action
right
could you put in more general terms
what am i doing kids there's a
that's that's the very specific thing
but you know what i mean there's the
motivation too
i just don't feel like like teaching it
and i've already made an arrangement
with you
to do something right what am i doing
what would you call that sort of action
backing out of your obligation okay
that's a good way to put it i
i'm going to back out of my obligation
i'm not good doing this by the way but
so don't don't start changing your
calendar i'm going to back out of my
obligation
all sorts of ways of expressing this
break a promise to you welch on a deal
i'm going to back out of my obligation
to you what's my motive
you just don't feel like it okay because
my i
don't feel inclined to to follow through
now could we express that more generally
it's the act of for any of you
if you were going to do that backing out
of an obligation
when you don't feel inclined to fulfill
it so if i do it
that's that's you know that action if
you do it it's that action
if she does it it's that action it's the
same action
in each case could you make that into a
rule
that's so the maxim is i will back out
of my obligation
when i'm trying to keep it
now we go on to the other parts can you
turn that
into a universal rule that would apply
to everybody yes
you could you could you can say it
but would that make sense this is where
we get to the first
how do you apply the first categorical
period
can we make it into a general rule that
whenever somebody has an obligation that
they don't particularly feel inclined to
keep
they will back up imagine what the
universe would be like
so do a sort of thought experiment with
yourself imagine a world in which
everybody whenever they
feel like it back out of obligations
that they've made
now don't think so much about the
consequences
this is the kind of a problem with khan
i mean if we were mill we'd think about
the consequences what would happen
um what would it be like if we had a
society let's just think about
consequences for a moment
what would it be like if we had a
society where anytime somebody
felt like breaking a promise or
obligation that they made to somebody
they'd just do it
yeah i guess because nobody would be
dealing with it very good yeah it would
be it would be chaos
um we saw something sort of like this
when we looked at the hobby and state of
nature
and the social contract contractarianism
is very uh
anything attuned to this oh i think you
think about it though
that a lot of promises we keep anyway
even though we don't have to
i think that'll still take place because
we still want the result that the
original promise
right but this is on the assumption that
we don't we don't care about the results
any time that we we don't care about the
result
we we break the promise
i don't think that you can really
just say okay well we don't care about
the result because that's well we're
imagining this
yeah we're carrying out again a thought
experiment
um now kant says it would go further
than that
those are consequences right the world
would look very different
kant says the very idea of promises
would break down
it would become nonsensical because what
does the promise actually mean
what are you doing when you make a
promise to another person
you are saying to them i'm going to do
this
regardless about how i feel about it
right that's what it means to make a
promise to somebody
that's why it's different than just
saying you know
so long as it pleases me i'll help you
out
or i'll do what i what i said
so the very notion of promise would
break down
that means that there's a contradiction
there
so you couldn't actually have that being
a universal law
that's very similar to the case that
kant uses that we're going to look at in
a moment
the person who says i'm going to i need
some money
nobody will give me any money if they
actually know what my credit looks like
and you know so i'm gonna
get a loan from somebody and there's no
way i can possibly repay it
but i need this loan so i'm going to
promise falsely
to them that i will repay their loan so
i can get what i
what i need kant says can you will that
to be
a universal law can you will that
everybody in that sort of situation
should behave the same way he says no
because then the very notion of
promising breaks down
it becomes incoherent
because what is it to make a promise
it's to say you're going to do what
you're
you said you're going to do it's sort of
like lying can you will that everybody
should whenever they feel like it lie no
because then lying and truth becomes so
confused
that that distinction breaks down
that's a big problem that shows you
there's certain things that you
can't will to be universal laws
and if you can't will them to be
universal laws that means that
really you have a strict duty not to do
those things
so kant says you have a strict duty not
to lie
not to make false promises not to
misrepresent things
and you you that's a strict duty who you
have to who
to other people right could you have any
um strict duties to yourself
do you think it kind of talks about one
let's say that your life gets so bad
that you want to kill yourself
right um
so what sort of scenarios should we make
you know you're you're involved with
somebody
you're engaged to be married you find
out that they're
they're cheating on you with
making a divorce with not just one of
your best friends but
all of your best friends and
they also emptied your bank account uh
because you know you were
dumb enough to set up a joint checking
account with them and it's all gone
as a matter of fact they left you in
debt and
the biopsy results are back and you got
cancer
and
everybody in your family dies what else
should we add to this
um like like job and the biblical
narrative you get oils
this is pretty bad right a lot of people
would want to kill themselves under that
sort of circumstance
now khan says you actually have a strict
duty not to kill yourself
why well let's think about what the
maxim would be
and then we'll see if we can rule it to
be a universal law
why does a person want to kill
themselves
what's their what's their motivation
what's their their train of reasoning i
i will kill myself
um because it's a sunny day no
i will kill myself when and what
they don't have anything in there okay
very good when i feel like i have
nothing left to live for
um when life has become intolerable
people would say people sometimes use
the phrase a life
that does not have a quality of life or
a life not worth living
although they tend to avoid that one
because the nazis used that one
and they called it a variable so they
have
a life not worthy of life
so the maxim is whenever my life becomes
intolerable valueless
then i will i will take my life i'll end
my life
can you will that to be a universal law
let's think first
about the consequences imagine how many
people would kill themselves
in cases like that
probably a lot right everybody
goes through some period where and
oftentimes it's periods of growth
this is awful i can't take this another
day
this is horrible um
so that would be good a lot of people
killing themselves
what else though let's go beyond just
the consequences
i mean well hang on one second we're
gonna
we're gonna do this go go beyond because
we want to do what what does
he's not actually concerned with the
consequences mill would be
aristotle kahn says does even the
concept make sense
that you use the very
life the inclination to life that you
have to
to a life that you feel would be worth
living to measure your life as being not
worth it and then end it
you're using the very thing by which
you're destroying
that very thing that khan thinks that's
contradictory
um so he would say it's your duty to
preserve your life
even if you don't want to i mean most of
us preserve our life all the time anyway
because we do want to
out of inclination right we have a
natural tendency to want to stay alive
but even if things get so bad that you
don't want to come let's say you have a
strict duty to yourself not not to kill
yourself
what are you gonna say i don't forget
oh sorry it's okay um let's think about
what we call
meritorious duties now can have those to
yourself you can have those to other
people as well
and there it's not so much whether
something could be a universal law
that's whether you can will it on your
universal law
so let's think about the one to the
south first kant
talks about this existence where you
don't do what he calls developing your
talents
and faculties so something very
different than what you're
currently engaged in here imagine being
on easy street
and never doing anything there are some
people who live like that right
and in this society you actually don't
need that much money provided
your wants are relatively little to live
in complete idleness
you know um
you could just i mean what what are the
sort of things
you you would do given the chance
let's say you didn't have to work for a
living at all
what would you be tempted to do that
would not make you in any way a better
person
or develop your mental faculties or
anything like that
play golf and video games all day play
golf and video games okay
golf actually you know golf is at least
walking around
and you know thinking about things video
games yeah i mean
there was this old joke about you know
it's it's too bad that there aren't any
advertisements for you know need
somebody with great thumb strength
and uh the ability to level out quickly
because there aren't you know we don't
need that but it is very entertaining
right
what else do people do yeah
you sit around drink all day
and you know you can explore that and
you know try out new recipes
and you know learn how to make cool
cocktails but you're not really
developing yourself as a person that way
um i mean you can actually go far with
it
academically i know a guy who is a
i think they call it a mixologist he can
he knows exactly why each drink should
taste the way it does
but that's developing your mental
faculties isn't it that's not just
sitting there and you know
opening the bloody mary mix and pouring
it in with the vodka and
stirring it up and then saying all right
let's party
what else would people
watch tv all day
sit around just eat you know
you could live that sort of life right
maybe throw it through it um you know
have sex
whenever you want to and
sleep whenever you want to right
you can you can have that sort of life
um could you will as your maxim i i will
not develop my talents and faculties
but instead just pursue enjoyment
um you could that could be your maxim
right
people do do that could you could you
will that to be a universal law
there's actually societies that you know
at least just in some degree have
behaved more or less like that i don't
know if you realize this but most
primitive societies
have a lot more leisure than we actually
do in modern society
because we're very work driven and in
some ways they're happier than us
i think though if you're going to make
something universal
well you have to take in consideration
even if not the consequences of other
people's motives because
not everybody wants the same thing that
you want
so oh yeah count doesn't talk about that
so much
he's assuming that you could say okay
we'll give everybody the same basic
structure and then see how
it would pan out to see whether it would
be universal law
that could be a problem and that would
tie in more with
his third formulation which means
essentially to respect the autonomy of
other people
which is their capacity to choose their
own ends
their capacity to choose their
motivational structures
right but the thing think just for a
minute about this could you will that
that that condition of the universal law
would there be anything inherently
contradictory in it
no you would you could have a world in
which
nobody cultivated their talents and
faculties
could you will it kahn says you couldn't
actually will it and here's why
you couldn't consistently that would
mean
that you would be willing not to develop
what is most distinctively human in you
your faculties your reason your
your will that which separates you from
the other animals remember aristotle
said something like this right the life
just pursuing
pleasure is kind of an animalistic life
it remains at a certain level it's god
it's not really worthy of human beings
what makes
us have our dignity
is that we can go beyond that even in
the ways that we do
play and enjoy ourselves
we go beyond that we impose all sorts of
rules and restrictions
and we raise ourselves to higher levels
think about sports for example you know
i mean monkeys play sports they run
after each other and they throw things
at each other
but is that golf or football or
basketball but if you want to actually
be good at a sport
the athletes in the class will tell you
this you have to put in a lot of hours
a lot of oftentimes dull hours right
doing things that you don't really feel
like doing that day
why to attain a certain level of
achievements
that's developing your faculties and
doing that isn't just developing
physical faculties it also develops the
mind
that's one reason why athletics are
still here in
colleges and universities that's one of
the justifications for having them that
they do develop the human mind to some
degree
as well so you couldn't will that
what about meritorious duties to other
people talks about
benevolence we've talked about this
before what's benevolence it's
doing good to other people um
do any of you contribute to charities or
volunteer or things like that
how many i'm not going to ask because
that would put people on the spot but
that's being beneficial right or you
take an interest
maybe you don't even you know do stuff
like that you take an interest in one
particular person you're gonna help them
out
maybe you study with them help them
improve their grades maybe you
bring them into your social circle
because they seem isolated that's
benevolence that's
contributing to what to somebody else's
happiness
happiness is not a bad thing
contributing to other people's happiness
is a good thing
you don't have to do it do you are there
some people who
they don't actually do anything bad to
anybody but they don't they don't
contribute to anybody's happiness
sure they don't they don't cheat they
don't lie they don't steal they don't
kill anybody
they don't sleep with anybody's wife or
husband but they don't help anybody up
they don't exercise any monopolies could
you will that
be a maxim could that be your max
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna hurt anybody
i'm not gonna help anybody here were you
insane
i was just when you asked the question i
was unclear about what it was
let's frame it i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna hurt anybody but i'm not going to
help anybody
either
could that be a universal law could
could that could you have a society like
that
kant says yes you could there's nothing
inherently
contradictory provided everybody follows
the rules
you know nobody cheats each other nobody
does anything that's explicitly wrong
but nobody seems to care about anybody
else or take care of them or anything
like
well that would be to whether everybody
would follow that would be empirical
and we're not worried about whether
people do have different motivations
we're interested in whether let's assume
everybody did have the same motivation
i'm not going to
i'm not going to hurt anybody but i'm
not going to help anybody either
could would it make sense to will that
no because if you will it then
us helping each other out is pretty much
the essential of society
so if we didn't want to help each other
out we wouldn't really have to will it
we wouldn't have to do anything
just everybody just says okay you know
what i'm not going to help you
and then you won't help you help me and
then
you know just kind of falls apart that
way god doesn't think society would fall
apart
he thinks we just have a whole bunch of
rules and everybody follows the rules
right why
if you were to will that you would be
willing a world
in which if you did need help
nobody would help you i'm not going to
hurt you
but you can starve it's got nothing to
do with me
but you know you're going to starve
or your house burned down
that's unfortunate should have had
insurance
you know it kind of thinks it doesn't
make sense to will that
you would be willing on a world that's
almost heartless
right when you in fact yourself might
need
somebody else's help so then wouldn't
that kind of
be going against this theory of thinking
that of not thinking about the
consequences
is thinking about the pure motivation
that is one of the
the problems that has been pointed out
with con this does seem
that this in this example of
consequentialism
scholars try to explain this away by
saying well we're not really thinking of
real consequences we're thinking of like
ideal
possibilities and what you know what
would be entailed in the idea i
actually do think that your criticism is
correct and then
at this point it does become
consequentialist
but it but it still makes sense to say
um
this would be one way in which you could
figure out that you do actually have a
duty to help other people
now that not a strict duty it's not like
if you don't help other people you're
there by a bad person
but if you want to be a good person you
want to be helping other people
if you want to be a good person you
ought to be developing your talents and
faculties now each one of these cases
can be dealt with in this with this
maxim too
act always so as to treat humanity
in yourself and others that's a very
important thing because you you could
be concerned with humanity and other
people but treat yourself as less than
humans is
not having the same dignity as other
people always as an
end always is something valuable
in itself never is just a means or to
put this really
in simple language don't just use other
people
so if
you hire
somebody because they're down and out to
do
things that you find demeaning
you're using them right you may be
giving them money
but is giving people money treating them
as an end
it's buying them and it could be through
affection it could be through
money it could be through power there
are ways to use people just as means to
an end
aren't there and all you've had the
experience at one point or another being
used by another person
if somebody somebody dates you because
they want to make somebody else jealous
they weren't really interested in you
maybe maybe you've done that to somebody
else i don't know or you flirt with
somebody
to make somebody else jealous that's
using somebody just as a means
right it's not it's not treating them as
valuable in and of themselves
hanging out with somebody because you
you like their toys is what kids do
right
we're gonna go over to johnny's house
johnny's a jerk but he's got a lot of
great toys
that's using little johnny as a means to
the enjoyment of his toys not treating
him
as an end part of maybe treating him as
an ad would be saying hey johnny you're
a jerk you need to change your character
right that sometimes you know being
harsh with people could be treating them
as an
end so it's not always just being nice
to people
but the question is whether you're doing
it for for their benefit
their genuine benefit not just their
perceived benefit
whether you're doing it for that reason
or just to get something out of it
yourself or maybe for somebody else you
could also
take yourself out of the equation you
react in such ways to benefit one person
at the expense of another person and you
don't you don't provide anything to that
other person
you're treating them as a means to the
end of
helping this other person so if we
execute people for example just to get
them out of the way
so that they're not a danger to other
people
i suppose that would be treating them as
just a means right
now think about these these cases
if you kill yourself because life has
become in your view no longer worth
living
you're treating humanity in yourself
as just a means
to enjoyment you're not treating
yourself as an end to something
worth something having dignity in and of
itself having a
inherent value or if you lie to other
people
if you lie to other people to get what
you want
you're not treating them as an end are
you you're treating them as a means
even if you lie to them seemingly for
their own benefit
like what are some of the lies that we
tell kids to
maybe make their lives better
is it really true that any one of you
can be president
practically no any of you like
you know come from a family of
gigantic means independently wealthy you
could possibly
be positive are any of you from you know
really well politically connected
families
that you could be president um
danny do you have like you know the
golden tongue that allows you to
convince people of all sorts of things
that um you know the rise through the
ranks
you could be president the rest of us
probably not
all right but we tell kids you can
accomplish anything you set your mind to
is that true can you really accomplish
anything you set your mind to i want her
to be a great artist
i mean that didn't happen and i did a
lot of drawing and painting and stuff
like that
i don't have any talent you know
you want to be a great artist you kind
of need the talent as well as
discipline don't you so what were you
going to say
the idea of anything's possible is
not necessarily everybody can be present
because obviously there's going to be
one present at the top
that's true yeah but you have to beat
each other up if you have
an idea and you want to do something you
work hard enough at it
there's no reason that you can't do it
so like there's no reason big reason
that
you know you can't become a great artist
yeah
maybe it's just not going to come as
easy to you as it will
someone else i'm not going to become a
great artist 20 years
well that's not something and i'm not
going to be an astronaut because i you
know
because i wear these even when i back
you know when i was in shape
and way back when well i mean now they
have laser eye surgery
you know yeah my my half brother had
that
he he likes it i thought about getting
that and i said i'm gonna wait and see
how it is for him about 10 years from
now
yeah you're right with the application
you can do a lot of stuff
and maybe if the intent is to try to
motivate the kids
and not to actually put this idea in
their head and truly anything is
possible
maybe then you could be treating them as
a net
but if it's just this bear sort of thing
you see on you know
popping up on the television every so
often anybody can be anything
that's a lie
you know you can only you can only be
the things that you actually
work really hard to get to and then
opportunity to open up for you know
if you put that as a universal rule that
i won't
lie and say anything's possible and you
say well
all right johnny you know it's really
unlikely that you're going to
own a business when you get older or
it's really unlikely that you're going
to be an accountant
yeah then that person just isn't really
going to be motivated to do much
but what do you know they know they can
do and a child at the age of six
doesn't really know that they can do a
whole lot
that's true but you wouldn't actually
say well you can't be an accountant
because that you wouldn't know that one
either right you just
leave it alone and say let's find out
what your aptitudes are and
we'll try to steer you in the right
direction and something a bit more
realistic
here's another one to think about in
terms of means and ends
i use this one every time i teach this
material
do i treat you as a means
you as students me as a professor
what do you think yeah i think in some
form yeah because you're like
you're like you're trying to instill
that you're saying the values and the
students
okay yeah that that's not the the answer
i've been
expecting but if i if i am trying to
instill certain values i could be
treating you as
as immense let's put that one on hold
for a minute that's a that's a good one
exactly i'm here in this classroom at
eight o'clock in the morning
uh because uh i get paid to be here
you know i i that's my profession
i enjoy doing it i i really like to
bring out um
the best in students and to to try to
instill
and then not necessarily sort of
indoctrinate them in certain ways of
thinking but to open those up for them
and say hey look
you could look at this and see things
this way i
get a lot out of that but think about it
this way
i'm getting money i'm getting to do what
it is that i like to do
and you've probably had some professors
who just like to be up on stage and you
know be
you know the professor be the authority
and stuff like that that could be a
motivation too
for each one of those i would be
treating you
as a means wouldn't i if i'm if i'm only
here because i'm getting paid
your means to an ad my my checkbook
if i'm here because i really like you
know the opportunity to read philosophy
and talk about philosophy
with with young growing minds and all
that
um well that one i could be treating you
as an s
if i'm actually trying to cultivate you
right
but if it's mainly about me getting to
do what i like to do that's just
treating you as a means
if it's just me being the big big
professor up on stage
getting to talk you know and have a
captive audience
for an hour and 15 minutes twice a week
i'm clearly treating you just as a means
then right
how could i be treating you has
an f in this activity to that extent
you wouldn't you wouldn't be allowed to
be paid
you couldn't enjoy being up there you'd
have to
well yeah
not just as a means so i could be
treating you as a means
provided i'm also treating you as an end
if i'm treating you as an ad then then
it could be okay
but the the issue is does the means
really matter if the
end's there anyway so let's say you're
up there just teaching
because you get paid and you enjoy it
but the end is still there you're just
not
conscious of
i mean it could happen that i i only
show up because i get paid
and you guys end up getting so much
benefit out of it because you know
the stars align just right you all
become these you know
great moral people intellectually hungry
you read kant aristotle thomas aquinas
the rest of your life and derive a lot
of benefit from it
but if i didn't intend that to be the
case can't
say i'm still you know the fact that
that happened
doesn't make me a good person for just
having been
in the right place at the right time i
have to actually
i have to intend that i have to make
that a deliberate part of my
my practice and motivation so how could
education
the process of education which does
involve money which does involve
you know an unequal power relation which
does involve all these other things
how could that be treating you as an f
that's something worth thinking about do
i treat you
as isn't that what would that look like
here's here's a clue why do i care about
what you what you guys major in
just to make conversation no because you
want to make sure that the material you
give us
is going to help us in our major and
potential career so that essentially is
the end
and the your development is is the end
your um your being able to function
better in your in your career is
and i also ask you what your majors are
so i can i can use
examples that will work well for
for your majors or draw on
experiences that i think you're likely
to have eventually
that's also treating you as
i do a lot of things in here that are
treating you as a means that make you do
a lot of work
and jump through a lot of hoops don't i
probably compared to some professors
probably making you more
that could be just treating you as a
means except at the end
is your development as a person
that's why we make you read stuff that's
why i
throw a hand outside you that's why i
give you
different types of assignments
so that's a case where and i'd like you
to think about
if you ever try to to make this work
think about cases like that before
immediately going out and saying ah
everybody uses everybody
that caught me showed me that any sort
of action
where where somebody's getting treated
as it means bad action can't do it
you've got to ask yourself is the person
also being treated as an end
that that's sometimes a difficult
determination to make you think about
this
yeah how would you know when there's
like if
you're if a person is being treated as
an enzyme
what's like what is the balance like
when does the positive outweigh the
negative
as well that way it's more like this
if the person is being treated as an
enemy then it's okay for them to be
treated
as physically
like one is bad and one is good
more like look this is this is always
good
so you know sometimes you do have to
treat people
as those means this will this will be an
interesting
one to end up kant actually thinks
he doesn't say this in what you've read
to go back to capital punishment
kant actually thinks that um capital
punishment is justified
you would think that based on this you
would say no way you can't do it right
you're treating the person as a means to
the end of
safety of other people or revenge or
something like that
kant says you're actually treating the
other person fully as a human being
by executing them because you're showing
them that the law does in fact apply
equally to everyone which every rational
agent
should be okay with um
it kind of seems that the end doesn't
really matter it's the
intention of the end and if you can
kind of make the reason the case that
okay this i'm treating this person as a
means and this is the end i want
yeah and you know you're kind of just
manipulating the end really
it's not really like saying okay that
this end is
manipulating like with killing people
you know in one instance you know it's
bad
because if your intention is bad
but if your intention is good like with
the death penalty then
that ends okay because your intention is
good
so i mean it's kind of contradictory
saying that okay you can't kill myself
or i can't kill someone else who's doing
bad things yeah even
even the the criminal i guess could it
wouldn't be
for khan it wouldn't be okay for the
criminal to kill himself in itself
even though that would like save the
state money and you know
expect the uh trauma and execution
but but uh according to count again
in metaphysical elements of justice
the convicted criminal
who's going to be executed should
realize that
that's what the law demands in the era
of law agent and
all of that so yeah there are some
peculiarities in the conscient doctrine
but i think you guys see that the
general trust of it right if you're a
conscient
duty takes precedence the intention is
really all that matters these are the
ways in which you
figure out whether the intention is a
good intention or not
so that that's that's that's it for the
semester